what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime out bro and we finally got
more information about Merlin's back
story after over 330 chapters
desperately waiting to learn more about
the most secretive and most mysterious
member of the seven deadly sins
we also learned a lot more about
Merlin's secret plan and her true
intentions including the reason why she
has been searching for the power of
chaos for thousands of years or at least
we got a reason I'm not sure that's the
whole reason but we'll talk about that
later in this video I will be delving
deep into the brand new information
about Merlin and I will also be
examining whether Merlin really betrayed
the seven deadly sins some of the things
that were recently revealed in the manga
definitely suggest that Merlin committed
treason against her comrades so I will
be talking about all of it right here in
this video if you enjoyed the seven
deadly sins content right here on the
channel please leave a like to let me
know and if you happen to be new to
anime uproar please don't forget to
subscribe and hit that notification bell
to turn on all notifications if you
really want to get notified you have to
go through the trouble of clicking the
Bell and then actually selecting the
option that says all otherwise you will
still miss a lot of our videos it's just
the way YouTube works feel free to hit
me up on Twitter and Instagram at anime
uproar for all the latest seven deadly
sins news and updates
finally this video will contain seven
deadly sins manga spoilers we're talking
about the latest developments in the
story so please proceed with caution you
have been warned in the recent chapters
of the seven of these sins the
mysterious Lady of the lake revealed a
lot of very interesting details about
Merlin and she has shed some light on
why Merlin has been searching for the
power of chaos for thousands of years
the Lady of the lake explains that she
herself was brought from chaos and that
she is also known as the saint of chaos
Arthur remarks that he has heard about
the Lady of the lake before and then he
remembers that she is said to have given
the legendary sword Excalibur to King
carve in the first one of Arthur's
Predator
and the first wielder of Excalibur in
some versions of the Arthurian legend
there is no sword in the stone and
instead Arthur gets Excalibur from the
Lady of the lake so this little tidbit
is consistent with our theory and legend
the only difference is that in this case
the Lady of the lake gave Excalibur to a
predecessor of Arthur rather than Arthur
himself Melly Otis is surprised that he
has never heard of this being called
chaos before
despite being alive for over 3,000 years
but the Lady of the lake explains that
Merlin has been deliberately hiding the
existence of the chaos deity from the
sins and from everyone else
we then finally get a proper flashback
to Merlin's childhood and we learned
more about the tragic life of this
secretive and mysterious sin as we
already know over 3,000 years ago there
existed another major kingdom or city or
city-state whatever it was in Britannia
in this city was called Bella Lewin the
capital of the Wizards the citizens of
beli Alwyn were apparently humans but
they were a superior form of human
because they possessed unique magical
powers and abilities these Wizards did
not side with either the demons or the
goddesses during the holy war and they
focused most of their energy on
researching magic in order to become
even stronger but although research and
the expansion of knowledge were their
primary goals on the record off the
record the Wizards also wanted to make
sure that they would be able to fight
against the higher-ranked goddesses and
demons if it ever came down to it they
wanted to ensure that they could keep
their neutral status in the war and
maintain their freedom and independence
and they were prepared to go to any
extent to accomplish this goal they
would single out any child who was born
with an aptitude for magic at a very
young age and they would then experiment
on the children as test subjects the
Wizards wanted to gain as much magical
knowledge from these children as
possible and they wanted to turn the
children into incredibly powerful
wizards who could one day protect them
from any external threats this is the
situation that Merlin was born into
and in fact Merlin was determined to
have the strongest and most unique magic
out of all the children in Bell yeah
Lewin the power of infinity because
Merlin was such a child prodigy when it
comes to magic all the wizards including
her father who was the leader of the
Wizards wanted Merlin to study and train
as much as possible in order to become
as strong as possible but despite her
immense talents Merlin was still just a
child and she wanted to have a normal
childhood she wanted to feel love and
kindness from her parents she wanted to
have friends but all she ever got was
more pressure more books to study more
tests to perform and so on she felt like
she was living in a prison rather than a
loving and supportive community
this caused Merlin to become sick of
everything and eventually she ran away
from home
but despite successfully evading the
Wizards for some time they eventually
caught up to her and just as they were
about to capture her and force her to
return to Bell yeah Lewin against her
well she was rescued by none other than
Melly Otis since Melly Otis saved her
and since he was the only person to ever
show her warmth and kindness
Merlin began developing feelings for
meliodas and she eventually fell in love
with him in order to get meliodas
attention she transformed into an adult
version of herself and she used infinity
to stop time so that she could always
look this way she hoped that in this new
form she would be able to win Melly Otis
over but that could never happen because
Melly Otis fell in love with Elizabeth
Melly Otis and Elizabeth were so deeply
in love that no matter what she did
Merlin never stood a chance with Melly
Otis now I have to say that I have very
mixed feelings about this reveal that
Merlin has apparently been in love with
Melly Otis this entire time does
meliodas really need a full-fledged
harem so late in the story he already
has Elisabeth Sunehri is in love with
him
DeeAnn was in love with him and now
Merlin I would understand if Merlin was
in love with meliodas at some point in
the past but the idea that she would be
in love with him all this time so much
so that she could not return ESCA norse
feelings for her even in his final
moments
just rubs me the wrong way it just feels
a bit unnecessary since Mellie Otis and
Elizabeth already have each other and
poor eScan or deserved some love too but
maybe I'm just biased because of my love
for Big Daddy sunshine let me know what
you guys think
wise meliodas such a chick magnet and
are you cool with this whole Merlyn
loving him thing or did it rub you the
wrong way like it did me moving on
despite her feelings of heartbreak and
frustration Merlyn could not hate
Elizabeth or meliodas because they were
both such kind and warm people
so Merlyn decided to return to belly
allowin and to throw herself into
magical training this is when she became
a glutton for knowledge
she used the search for more and more
magical knowledge as a way to distract
herself from her unrequited love but no
matter how hard she threw herself into
her studies and research she never felt
fulfilled then one day she heard some
older wizards talking about chaos an
entity that was born amidst ancient
stars far far away and the very entity
which is said to have created this
entire world in the first place
including the demon king the supreme
deity and the sacred tree of the fairies
eventually the supreme deity created the
celestial realm and the goddess race the
demon king created the demon realm and
the demon race and the sacred tree
created the fairy realm and the fairies
next chaos created the Giants but the
Giants were obsessed with power and
strength and they just kept fighting
each other in order to prove their
supremacy as warriors chaos was
disappointed by this simple-minded
behavior so it went on to create the
human race the humans became the perfect
race the one closest to chaos because
they were the most complex they were not
one-dimensional they could be both
aggressive and kind ruthless and
compassionate beautiful and despicable
all at the same time they were creatures
of both light and darkness and this made
them closest to chaos out of all the
races when they saw that chaos favored
the human race the demon king and the
supreme deity became jealous and they
decided to seal chaos away so that their
dominion over their own clans would not
one day be taken away by their creator
once she found out about this
Merlin spent the last three millennia
trying to resurrect chaos Merlin was
convinced that if she could do something
as drastic as resurrect chaos the first
and most powerful being the creator of
everything and everyone in this world
then her hunger for knowledge would
finally be satiated and her starving
heart would finally be fulfilled in
order to resurrect chaos Merlin had to
meet a number of strict conditions
including the outright defeat of the
demon king and in order to achieve this
she used the seven deadly sins
at first the sins refused to believe
that Merlin has been keeping such major
secrets from them this whole time and
they refused to believe that Merlin used
them in order to achieve her hidden
goals but the Lady of the lake reveals
that Merlin has been secretly working on
her plan since the time of the previous
holy war it turns out that she was the
one who asked the giant craftsmen da
buzu to forge the coffin of eternal
darkness in the first place Merlin
initially wanted to use it to seal away
the demon king and the supreme deity and
it is clear that none of the sins had
any idea that this was the case Merlin
also intentionally delayed her spell to
stop time during the first fight against
the demon king in order to allow him to
be resurrected and she even reactivated
the deadly curse on Elizabeth after Meli
Otis had broken it
and finally Merlin was the one who drove
the sins combo move into the lake during
their final battle against the demon
king the sins still refused to believe
this but I have to say that if this is
true then it is clear that Merlin did
indeed manipulate and betray the seven
deadly sins at least to some extent
Merlin explains that in order to revive
chaos it was not enough to seal away the
demon king and the supreme deity one of
them had to be completely destroyed so
that the balance between light and
darkness would be disrupted she also
explains that she needed explosive
magic in order to resurrect Arthur and
that is why she sent the combo move into
the lake although if she hadn't done
that then the force of the magic would
have caused much greater collateral
damage Mele Otis can't believe what he
is hearing he asks if Merlin really
restored
Elizabeth's curse putting her life in
danger in the process but Merlin says
that if she hadn't done that Mele Otis
would not have been committed to
destroying the demon king once and for
all
since meliodas main goal was to break
Elizabeth's curse
Merlin needed to keep him motivated in
order to destroy the demon king because
of course without the demon Kings
complete destruction the balance could
not have been disrupted and chaos could
not have been resurrected so at this
point Merlin explicitly admits that she
was the one who reactivated the curse
although she says that she was also the
one who sayed elizabeth from the effects
of the curse and while that's all well
and good reactivating the curse could
have killed Elizabeth what if something
had happened to Elizabeth that Merlin
couldn't have controlled like what if
Elizabeth was really killed while Merlin
was distracted by something else if that
had occurred Elizabeth's death would be
on Merlin's hands and I really do think
that Merlin's willingness to take such a
risk does amount to treason against the
seven deadly sins we can argue that
Merlin's betrayal was limited in scope
that she was there to make sure
Elizabeth would be okay that she had a
good reason for what she was doing and
so on but at the end of the day she put
Elizabeth's life in danger after
everything when the Otis and Elizabeth
went through for 3,000 years and she did
it without ever revealing her true
intentions to the sins this may not make
Merlin an outright villain or anything
but it definitely makes her a traitor
she committed a serious sin against her
best friends and comrades
Meli Otis and the sins the man to know
if Merlin only assembled the seven
deadly sins in order to use them to
achieve her goals the Lady of the lake
chimes in saying that hating someone so
much you want to kill them but being
able to love them at the same time is
the essence of being human that seeming
contradiction is what makes humans so
unique and what makes them closer to
chaos than
other race chapter 337 ends as the Lady
of the lake wonders whether Merlin and
the sins since they are all from
different races will ever truly be able
to understand each other and this whole
thing left me really confused I mean
okay I liked the fact that we finally
got more of Merlin's backstory and I
thought that this idea of her being
experimented on as a child did her
unique magical abilities was a nice
touch
it showed us that despite being
incredibly gifted with magical talent
Merlin still had a pretty hard and
difficult life
her blessing was also a curse because it
led her to not being able to have a
proper childhood because she was
constantly pressured to get stronger and
stronger and so she never got to feel
love and support from her parents or
from her community she felt like a
prisoner in her own home which prompted
her to run away from home altogether all
of that was fine and I really enjoyed
learning more about Merlin but as I said
earlier the whole Merlin loves meliodas
thing was a bit disappointing to me if
she had a crush on him at some point
that would be fine
but the idea that she apparently loved
him this whole time and that her whole
gluttony for knowledge was just a way to
distract herself from his unrequited
love it just didn't sit right with me
also if I was pawn I would keep Elaine
far away from le Otis because this guy
just gets all the chicks but beyond the
whole love thing I am wondering why
exactly did Merlin go through all of
this trouble for 3,000 years to
resurrect chaos I mean she was even
willing to repeatedly deceive her
friends and to put her so-called big sis
Elizabeth in direct danger so why was
she so determined to resurrect chaos
what is the real reason is it just
because she is obsessed with obtaining
more knowledge about this mysterious
entity or does she want to use the power
of chaos to do something important like
potentially revived the dead including
esken or or does she believe that the
only way to end the cycle of light and
darkness and end the wars and suffering
is to bring back chaos or is she
motivated by something else entirely we
still don't know for sure it suggested
that it's because of her love for
meliodas but then there's other
indications that this might not be the
whole story so I just don't know
sure to give me your thoughts down in
the comments below what are Merlin's
true motivations behind wanting to
resurrect chaos and why is she willing
to go so far to do it finally what was
all that stuff at the end with the Lady
of the lake saying that she doesn't know
whether members of different races will
ever be able to truly understand each
other I feel like the whole concept of
the seven deadly sins story was that the
seven sins even though they're from
different races have been working
together and being good friends this
entire time there are also multiple
examples of members of different races
falling in love with each other
so even bringing up the idea that
different races may not be able to truly
understand each other this late in the
story just doesn't make sense to me feel
free to hit me up with your take down in
the comments below a big shout out to my
visual editor Dakota broski for being so
reliable and helping us get these videos
out to you guys at the rate that we have
been doing please show the man some love
and check out his youtube channel his
weeb credentials are top tier and he is
one of the amazing people who make what
we do possible if you enjoyed this video
you want to see more seventh at least
sense content right here on the channel
please leave a like to let me know and
if you happen to be new to anime uproar
don't forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications you can also hit me up on
Twitter and Instagram at anime uproar
for all the latest channel and seven
deadly sins news and info I want to give
a big thank you to all of our anime
uproar patrons who support our work and
make videos like this one possible with
all the problems facing YouTube right
now patrons are more important than ever
and we really appreciate it
special thank you to our pro hero tier
patrons including the one and only
Gilgamesh nothing but a fan Jason Wilson
Kings ell drous fanny dolla beat Anatole
Cassatt's kee alpha do on Hale Cruz and
team Sparky 65 and I can't forget the
ones who rise above all other clans a
massive thank you to our the 1 and tier
patrons including Ingrid ah
Ilona out of mana Mac makoto-kun the
world stealers and the school bus if you
enjoy our videos and you feel they
provide value for you please consider
becoming a patron even a single dollar
will give you access to our patron
exclusive
scored and your name will appear in our
videos along with these legendary people
as always thank you guys so much for
watching and until next time see us
space Cowboys
[Music]